we have a voicemail number which is 2192
david p
uh this is a voicemail that relates to
media literacy
unfortunately i'm worried i'm worried
this is one of those voicemails that
attacks me
for things that i don't actually claim
to be
take a listen uh hey david
uh i'm really upset um
honestly you and your coverage of
you know just the news oh no especially
in the lab i mean i've never really been
a um fan of your method i think that you
have this sort of mainstream media um
manufacturing consent sort of technique
where you pretend
like you you're not biased or that bias
is
wrong or that you're somehow like
objective and just calling balls and
strikes when you're clearly ejecting
your opinion
okay so this goes on for three minutes
but guys come how many times we
we need media literacy you know we hear
fox news viewers can't distinguish
between news and opinion programming and
fox uses it to their advantage
i have always been unequivocally
unapologetically clear this is an
opinion show this is a left-wing show
i do my best to be objective with the
facts and then i give you my opinion
which is a left-wing opinion
so criticize me for something real but
criticizing me for pretending that this
is not a left-wing opinion program come
on guys
come on we're in trouble if this is what
we're dealing with we've got a great
bonus show for you today
and we have a live debate stream tonight
joe biden versus donald trump join me
at 8 30 pm eastern time i'll see you
there